[Música]
muchas veces nos han dicho que debemos
soñar y soñar en grande sin embargo
entre más grande sea nuestro sueño nos
resulta más difícil empezar al iniciar
un proyecto encontramos muchas barreras
algunas de ellas son reales pero la
mayoría existen solo en nuestra mente un
simple ejemplo hace unos años al estar
buscando un programa maestría pensaban
incae como algo imposible que son las
personas con muchísimo dinero y con
promedios excelentes podían ingresar sin
embargo un buen amigo me sugirió que
simplemente preguntar por información me
acerqué y pregunté y descubrí que hayan
opciones y oportunidades hoy estoy a tan
solo tres meses de graduarme gracias a
que logre superar esta barrera y bueno
también todos los cursos que hemos
llegado hasta el momento muchas veces no
empezamos un proyecto por miedo a
fracasar o nos detenemos ante una pre
concepción equivocada
hace 5 años mi tía maristela me pidió
que la acompañara a unos barrios más
turísticos está rica a enseñar cómo
tocar la guitarra sin conocer muy bien
el trasfondo del asunto le dije que si
un sábado por la mañana atravesamos la
ciudad y después del parque y versiónes
todo ese territorio era nuevo para mí
después de pasar un tajo vivo
vicky apareciendo casas casas y más
casas algunos talleres algunos negocios
pero sobre todo casas hechas todas con
latas de zinc fue impresionante ver
tantas personas bien en ese lugar casi
32 mil personas viviendo en la carne
llegamos a un salón comunal y junto a
otros seis voluntarios atendemos a más
de 60 niños que llegaron curiosos de lo
que les podíamos enseñar cada voluntario
tomó una esquina y demás clases de
guitarra violín flauta y saxofón
mi tía tenía un sueño desarrollar la
escuela música en este barrio escasos
recursos como sistema integración social
para los niños y jóvenes de la zona este
sueño era grande y complejo para
lograrlo requería con muchísimos
recursos didácticos económicos de
infraestructura y sobre todo el capital
humano al inicio no contaba con todos
los proyectos con todos los recursos
para iniciar un proyecto de esta
magnitud
simplemente conocí a músicos como yo y
por supuesto tenía muchísimas ganas
siente seamos lograrlo así comenzado
todos toda la semana se realizan
talleres de enseñanza musical
llegaban los voluntarios que yo veía que
habían más voluntarios y más asistentes
algunos voluntarios no sabían de música
pero sabían de idiomas sabían de baile
no sabían algún idioma y querían
compartirlo y enseñarlos con los
miembros de la carta en las actividades
se generaba una interacción muy
enriquecedora de amigable entre todos
los participantes no importaba la edad
no importaba el género la nacionalidad
ni su estrato social yo siempre me
preguntaba quién es el más beneficiado
todo esto por una parte los miembros de
la comunidad aprendía en algún idioma
algún instrumento musical o algún
deporte pero por otra parte los
voluntarios aprendían a enseñar lo que
saben y también se sensibilizan ante la
realidad del país poco a poco se fueron
generando relaciones y alianzas con
con colegios y universidades para ese
programa de voluntariado y labor social
también se realizaron muy buenas
relaciones con empresas privadas
quebradas instrumentos musicales equipo
de computación material didáctico o
tiempo de sus empleados el proyecto fue
creciendo a gran velocidad conformando
lo que es hoy si país que significa
sistema integral de formación artística
para la inclusión social después de
muchos esfuerzos si país logró finalizar
la construcción de un edificio de cuatro
pisos de madera ahí mismo en a carpio
actualmente cuenta que más de 80
trabajadores y voluntarios más de 500
miembros de la comunidad asisten a los
120 talleres del programa entre los
cuales destacan violín guitarra
percusión solfeo idiomas como inglés
mandarín también trompeta clarinete
baile folclórico flamenco teatro
deportes como judo karate voleibol
también se tienen programas musicales
como la orquesta sinfónica que se ha
presentado en mejores teatros del país
pero conjuntos del blog también
proyectos relacionados con la
sostenibilidad e inclusive la
agricultura y energía también programas
de educación y de producción textil
la realidad del proyecto ha superado por
mucho las expectativas del sueño
original gracias al apoyo de muchas
personas e instituciones pero lo más
importante es que si país hoy es una
realidad porque una persona de un sueño
y empezó a seguirlo
así como este proyecto pues también
puedes alcanzar tus sueños si maristela
si hubiera detenido al no tener un
espacio para enseñar música hoy todos
los niños y jóvenes de la carpio no
tendrían las oportunidades que tienen
gracias al programa
si aquel amigo no me ha dicho que
preguntar por información de incae hoy
no sabría todo lo que me ha enseñado los
cursos de la maestría no habría hecho
tan buenas relaciones con personas de
toda la región latinoamericana ni
tampoco habría tenido tan buenas
experiencias como los que vivió todo
este año
para iniciar un proyecto basta con
hacerse tres simples preguntas a donde
quiero llegar
qué necesito para lograrlo y qué
recursos tengo disponibles hoy para
aprenderlo si logras responder estas
preguntas entonces qué estás esperando
para empezar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]